starting my life was kind of rough i had
an awful battle the doctor set my
parents down and said my life was
fragile perspective is the game
i guarantee the name just put your head
down do the work and everything will
change
sympathy helping fields yeah that's what
i wanted be a patient held a tricky
[Music]
what's good everybody good morning good
morning good morning
uh really really really excited to be
here
this morning friday uh dustin how are we
fantastic what's been going on nothing
just got my sidekick here today
you ordered that no my girlfriend got it
off like
one of her followers or she follows
someone this was like a year ago
and she went to brooklyn to get it for
me
yeah red cheeks brian good morning
matthew hunter from australia good
morning
sarah script good morning good morning
share squads
in the building i see some people really
sharing this morning with this super fun
um let me just go to my mentions let's
see yes
wine and traveling doing a good job with
the um
with the oh here we go here's the url
here's the url
good one
that was trippy i was we're on a lag and
i was like looking at it doesn't
all right chris uh abel franco always
good to see you man thank you for
joining as always
joelle big ups on youtube
daisy nicole good morning on youtube joe
f
good to see you on was that linkedin yes
that is linkedin the linkedin
is popping share share share share share
share
share share share share share squad is
in the building please take the url
right now and share it
and let's have some friends uh join us
uh let's rock and roll i'm ready to go
t what's good what's good man this is a
real full circle moment for me right now
just letting you know
thank you bro thank you for your energy
where you where are you at i'm in
downtown l.a
love it nice and early 603 in the
morning i apprecia i appreciate it
oh man this is just like i'm excited to
meet jesus basically
this is good what's cooking give us some
context what's your question
so right now i'm on tick tock um
i followed your advice my brother saw
your video if you're not an artist
if i mean if you're an artist and you're
not on tick tock what what are you doing
i started uh doing music on there
putting my music on there changed my
whole name changed my whole vibe in two
months
i put a song out uh i get a rolling
stone article
it starts out with like 6 000 likes
and then it goes to 60 000 likes
an hour three million streams later and
is on one song on my first song
that's crazy talk about like the way i
got here
i drank the [ __ ] kool-aid my dude
dropped out got kicked out lived in the
living room for four years
just so i could try everything acting
modeling just landed on songs
now that i have something rolling i want
to know
when do you know like when you finally
broke through you got your hit
when do you know when it's time for the
next one because
i think it's i think what what a lot of
people make a mistake on is they don't
squeeze the first hit enough
yeah i almost did that i got to 100 000
plays and then i was like guys i'm gonna
[ __ ] hold back and
see how long this goes you know yeah to
me to me
it's about making sure you pop off on
every other platform
right now what i'm trying to make sure
people that win
on tick tock realizes forget about the
you know yesterday executive order 45
days for that's to sell we'll see if it
lands in microsoft where it goes
you know that those are things we can't
control
the things we can control is when that
song pops off
you could have sat down and went to
8 000 and i'm not kidding when i say
this number because i lived it in 2011
on twitter
you know you could have gone to 8 000
youtubers
and sent them a message on youtube with
the link to rolling stones
with the link to the streams with the
link to your tick tock and be like yo
you know if there's anything i can ever
do for you i admire your success on this
platform
all you need is one of those people to
put the song
into their vlog and that boom that start
like to me it's like
keep pushing right like taking all that
tick tock energy
right if you look at you know someone
like charlie demilio who kind of rose to
the tippy top of tick tock
you know she was also able to cross
pollinate on youtube and twitter
and instagram and so i want to make sure
that you're
taking that energy and using it to
take that audience and take them on a
journey with you in the four to five
other places where you live
and then more importantly reaching out
to other places that can amplify
the heat that you got on this one song
think about a hit song
for an artist that was already
mainstream they're playing and squeezing
that song for like an 18 month period
you know how sometimes you put on like
the grammys in the background
and somebody's like performing and song
and you're like that shit's two years
old
yeah yeah yeah so just yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so when you're spread when you're
spreading out this content do you think
that it's really important to share some
content that is for that platform or do
you think that like i think it's
distribution
i need yes you need to be content and i
always talk about that i'm going a
different place
all together i'm saying when you have
something hit you spend
all your time trying to amplify that
so like it's almost like taking that
original video that hit
and then literally reaching out to all 7
000 websites that are like
covering pop culture and hitting the
bottom of like
news at you know buzznews.com and
you're like oh you see this like like
when the hit happens after four years of
grinding and bleeding
for the hit ironically you got to go
harder for the next four months yeah
yeah yeah yeah and a lot of people see
it and they're like
we made it right and it's amazing and
i'm like no no no no
now like stay in a cocoon of 18 hours a
day
like just hitting up literally everybody
literally
make every single platform ban you or
stop you
from for an hour to pause because they
think you're spamming because all you
want to do is make more people aware of
it
makes sense um do you think how much of
that should be organic and how much
should that be promotion like paid
i think again i think you're thinking
about the audience
yeah and i'm talking about business
development oh
okay got it i'm talking about you
sitting down
and your crew and literally emailing the
editor of
every gossip music like
like pop culture got it you want you
know i'm talking about
literally going to youtube and literally
sending a message
to 8 000 vloggers and saying would you
like to use this song
in your next video let me know and
having 13 of them say yes
yeah because only 98 of them even open
the message
knowing that you're messaging for 12
hours
okay 2011 to 2000 excuse me 2007 2011
i spent 12 13 hours a day
get hitting up people to be aware of
wine library tv
replying to every single tweet it was
all about distribution
but but strategic business development
distribution not organic i'm gonna post
this or i'm gonna run
ads no no i'm gonna try to get other
like you gotta hit up
king batch and be like you see this yeah
just so that it's there's context it's
not just like a red like a random guy
with maybe a song i have all this like
other
editorial stuff that's alright yeah i
would i probably have three links the
original tik tok
the spotify stream or soundcloud and the
rolling stones article
it's you know if you write batch and be
like batch i've been following you since
vine i have a lot of respect for you
yeah kudos you're somebody that really
did it you worked hard
you know this is me it's 98 likely he's
not gonna see it what people don't
understand is if you do that ten
thousand times
the two percent times that ten thousand
changes the course of your career
yeah i mean nobody wants to do the like
where i always win is i like dirt
more than after party
like i get excited when i can sit and
just like
for 12 straight hours try to get people
to know about something
yeah i like the work i like the
two years i spent learning about pokemon
and sports cards
when i didn't have time the last two
years and now it's popping
but like i don't like it as much as two
years ago when it was dirt
i like the grind of it
and and that's what that's the mo that
is the single most important
zone to go into when something pops
second that song popped
when did this happen this happened i
posted the song in may 29th
it's called stuck in the middle love
we're still in it then in my opinion
like to me right now you just literally
hit up every influencer and every media
outlet
and everybody who's got an audience
whether it's them as an individual
you should hit up morning you should go
to see the top
podcasts and be like yo do you want to
interview me about how this song popped
yo do you want it like you just need to
go ask
a hundred thousand times like literally
get your favorite beverage in foods
if you want to scale it get your loved
ones and your homies
and like literally go into pr mode
for a month no new song no ads not even
i'm willing to give up content on social
which i always want
just so you biz dev the [ __ ] out of the
story
and the song yeah just just just totally
that makes a lot of sense man it's it's
about
what can you impact to the amplification
of it
yeah i've been focused a lot on the
consumer like probably a hundred percent
of the kids i love that i love that
that's how you got to the hit
but now that you have the hit we need to
manifest the outcome
we need to do the 2021 version of what
scooter braun does for ariana or bieber
because they do the song part but he
makes
it happen behind the scenes distribution
we need to do the part that
in 1970 if i was your manager because i
paid off every radio host in america
i was like yo put this on got it or
because i was homies with dick clark got
you on countdown
or because i was like because i like did
a favor for the soul train
producer got you on it's about exposure
got it yeah yeah yeah it's about this
you're living in the matter right now
right now right now right
exactly i just think i need to be on
every single [ __ ] podcast
and every like like try to get on uh
twitch live streams and stuff like
that and you could get at least 25 to 50
articles
on newspapers of this guy song went
viral on tik tok because everybody wants
to write about tik tok right now
yeah and the whole story is like the way
that i did my tick tock was i
i basically showed every single part of
it like i was out i like
filmed myself in the verizon store still
working in the verizon store
and having that song blow up and i'm
still there like i'm still working i'm
going to work it's happening in like
four hours
by the way by the way by the way that is
a story in itself
yeah yeah you know so like but get as
much distribution as possible
by the way and the the the chat is
exploding so everybody in the chat
that's saying i want to do something
with him
his you know his instagram's right there
so just dm it yeah guys check out the
song stuck in the middle music video
just coming out on monday we filmed that
it's so great so if that's coming out
monday it's a perfect opportunity
that link you need to basically email
and direct message and publicly reply
with that link
a hundred thousand times think about
that number
okay because because you might you might
be going into it pre this talk
at zero yeah because you're thinking i'm
gonna put it out we're gonna do our
thing
and i'm gonna go to your point consumer
and i'm looking for you to do a hundred
thousand outreach on b2b
um business yeah yeah we gotta we got a
nylon
um premiere on it nylon magazine
premiere on so should we share the
premiere should we just try to get
everyone to share the video
i mean after the premiere as well is the
on the nine line
is the youtube or vivo video embedded
um i'm pretty sure it's going to be
embedded i don't know it's going to be
the article and then the video is going
to be right there
yeah so i think that'll be fine and
that's a good look you know
yeah that's it you you got to you got to
grind that url
into the ground every social everything
go to get you or your best friend that
knows twitch
go to every twitch yeah player and be
like yo can you play this while you're
streaming
you see where i'm going it's just
attention
did you ever play video games madden or
2k or any of this stuff yeah man i
played it right
beautiful so you know how some songs
popped off
because they were the songs while you
were building franchise mode and nobody
knew what the [ __ ] that song was prior
to it
yeah it just [ __ ] got it
totally clear i go man my team's gonna
have a [ __ ] field day after this
and you need to set the tone for the
team you need to be the one
sending it out you're grinding in
verizon so you've got the grind in you
you just need to basically lay in bed
from midnight to two in the morning
because you want this so bad and this is
your moment
another dm another dm another dm another
dm
another reply on twitter once literally
go to twitter right now i'm gonna do it
myself right now i'm going to twitter
and i'm saying looking for
a new song people literally tweet
things like i'm just looking for a new
song to listen to her
oh man such a good one right there
right and so like you just reply be like
yo like
literally and this this is literally
what i did nobody knew who the [ __ ] i
was
in 2000 and [ __ ] seven i just went to
twitter and
anybody that said the word wine i
replied with value
damn dog that one is a wild one right
there
you know what i mean oh okay that's
great i've been doing i've been doing
the whole
reply to every comment thing but this is
fishing you're you're you're hosting
but i want you to go fish oh man that's
a great one i
i i know what i'm going to because
there's downtime in the store so i
literally just
that's it you know that to live in the
blueprint
get a job that pays you that gives you
unlimited down time so you can work on
your bus
you win twice you get a little paper
right because you got to live
but you actually are getting paid to do
your grind
exactly exactly i i even run the store
by myself like i'm for the next five
days in the store
all right i gotta bounce love you bro
thank you
back in the middle we went deep there i
like that
fishing fishing fishing
go ahead hey how are you
i'm good i'm good how are you i'm very
well
where are you right now so to be honest
i'm in austria in the midst of the
mountain and i have an amazing view
right now i love it can you can you show
us or yes sure
so if you see it here
beautiful yeah yeah it's amazing it's
amazing and i just arrived 10 minutes
ago and i set up everything so i was
like
prepared for our talk because i'm so
excited about it
um and thank you so much for for being
with me here happy to do it what's on
your mind
so my first question for you is did you
get my 300 postcards to your office
i know it arrived i just haven't been
able to
hold them yet but yes i'm aware of them
thank you yeah so that was actually me
um i didn't know that i didn't know that
that's awesome yeah
so basically on every postcard there is
a quote of you
saying something featuring something you
said in your talks and
to give you a little background story on
this um
so i'm a journalist and i'm so
passionate about it right i was working
for the german press agency
for years in brussels everywhere in the
world and then i got self-employed and i
thought okay
so my mission is really to inspire
people with sustainable content i really
want to crack to boost i want to
um i want people to be more aware of
themselves and also
um with their company maybe as a leader
as the ceo or something
so what i started i have a podcast with
red bull i have a column in business
insider
and additionally to that i um host
events for instance for google for
facebook for sap
where i set up topic which is about like
a
society relevant topic like for instance
i did an african dinner for google
or i did a tree sustainable event for
sap
um all that kind of stuff and on top of
that i
just started a series called meet your
mentor where i'm reaching out to the
most inspiring people this is also the
reason
why i sent you the postcard because i
really wanted to have you on my show
um to talk about one life question right
so that can be um nico rosbeck the
formula one champion how
he became from a formula one champion to
a tech investor in green tech or um we
had annie puddycon we had jay shetty we
had klitschko
like we had them all right it was so
easy and we just
sent them a test yeah amaruso i just
asked right
so um right now i'm in this position i
know that i can do it
everything is possible in my mind and
i'm so
um convinced of this idea spreading the
world but
um yeah on the other hand i'm a
storytelling machine but i know that
there's so much more potential to bring
it in the world
so right now i'm a little bit stuck like
i have my instagram
it's okay i mean i'm popular in germany
it's okay
i'm very active on social media and it's
not a lack of motivation but maybe more
lack of a strategy how i can really
bring everything together
and spread it like the next oprah
winfrey thing so this is my question to
you
if you're the ceo of my storytelling
company what are your next three steps
what is the most i mean look you'll
appreciate this because it's like
living my blueprint the number one thing
i think you should debate
is doing a daily vlog and having
somebody follow you around 24 7.
yeah you know who's your drock
you know to me that's one thing to
debate number two is
uh if for everybody's watching if you
google garyvee content model i always
think you need
one major thing that everything
feeds off of that is consistent so even
in cobit
i immediately went and created tea with
garyvee because i knew i needed a thing
because i need content for all my other
channels
it sounds like your podcast is that how
consistent is that
well we also started it in keratin and
for the moment we are publishing every
week which is really high paced because
um yeah we're having like all these big
players from the us as well so we are
constantly
texting coordinating i'm recording it
preparing it but
um it works it works and we don't really
have a big team right we are like a
team of four people um and it's like a
startup mentality
um but the thing i mean let me help you
and everybody who's watching right now
anybody who wants to be an intern
whether it's for
you know i can't speak for a lot of
whether it's free or
for experience and exposure or whether
she's got a couple more dollars to be
able to spend but please dm
her because what i've been trying to do
more of i thought about it and this is
my first moment here is doing a little
more matchmaking between the community
and the people on the show um your team
got four could be team of eight
very very very quickly probably just
happened right now i have
you know just listening to you carefully
i think there's probably a lot of my
audience that will resonate with your
story so hopefully that works so
that's one thing to consider that
there's just a lot of people sitting at
home right now that
are accountants but want to be graphic
designers or want to be video editors
and maybe your exposure and notice what
i do with babin
and drock and dustin and india and
stunwin and zach i try to put a pedestal
on them
so that they can go get a different job
if they want to
so you got to be kind to people that
give to you but there
keep that in mind so keep go to me it's
definitely
the pillar content and patience remember
you're looking at gary
the garyvee that everybody now knows
that i would argue is probably
had a lot a lot of momentum for the last
three years
that took 11 years to get to that point
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but the thing
is
go ahead please sorry um what kind of
people would you recruit
because i think i have great people in
my team but let's assume a lot of people
make
makers makers designers
video people writers yeah audio
people that make you don't not you know
people that know how to run ads
because if you want to give her him a
thousand dollars to you know get more
on tick tock or more on facebook or more
on youtube so
um an ad person but then designers and
video people
writers because linkedin maybe you want
to make decks so
writers designers video people and and
definitely one or two pro
as you grow it project managers general
managers people that can
you know be the architects of these
individuals while you're doing your
thing
that's amazing yeah and how do you
structure your content how do you
organize yourself with the
team everything which which is happening
like on different platforms instagram
tick tock everything
we've done both over the last four years
where everybody works on everything
and and then we've recently we're siloed
into
you know zayn and destiny are on
are on instagram and you know
ian raghav are on linkedin and you know
you know uh justin and katie are an
influencer
so we've allocated people into tasks
amazing um so yeah but at first when
you're smaller
everyone has to do everything a little
bit sure yeah
yeah so um i would amazingly appreciate
appreciated
if you also want to help promote meet
your mentor because to me
it's really an amazing format and we as
i said we have all these
big big names like we even reached out
to bernie sanders
so where where where do people find it
because we're promoting right now here
we go
yes yes so if you go on my instagram you
will find the first episodes
yes um we just released annie potty comp
last week was an amazing interview we
had nico rosberg as i said we had sophia
moruso so far um we have amazing people
coming up jay shetty is part of the show
in september
um and yeah i mean i honestly i'm so
happy about it because right now there
is not a great profit behind it yet
but as you said i mean there's always
patience and
what i would do i just followed you but
you know what i would do
your thank you uh thank you uh dustin
your link tree there
i would change that to directly to
the podcast so the show is a podcast
like where does it live
so it lives on youtube right now and on
my igtv
yeah so i would i would 100 change that
link tree for now
to to your youtube okay
all right i will because if you click
the link tray you can click it dustin
if you click it what ends up happening
is
and i love link tree i use it all the
time and i think they're doing a good
job
but that's what's going on there is that
working i'm gonna come back
it has to switch no worries
yeah hold on i want it i wanna i wanna
make this point because i think it's
going to help people
i change my url in my instagram profile
all the time
to whatever's needed right here you're
giving them which i like
you know but i don't like the visual of
like that i just want to
you're you're creating an extra step of
friction yeah
when by far right now your number one
thing
is to build up this for example contact
they can do that on dm if they really
want to right in the functionality so
being strategic about that default url
is very important and i think right now
i would definitely put it to the direct
youtube for now if that's where it's
living
yeah that works definitely and also if
there is someone
listening to it right now i would love
to have someone in the team who's really
able to distribute the content let's say
we have one amazing interview and how
can you put it into small pieces and put
it everywhere
that that's that's the designers and the
video people they have to also know how
to do that
a lot of you have you ever have you ever
looked at um the garyvee content model
dustin can you pull that off real quick
i will
abduct and pull this up right now for
everybody's watching google
garyvee content model um
that's you on it
yeah we'll just check it out yeah so
right here
if you google this there's an 86 point
slide
that i made for free to help people it's
almost got a million views it talks
about keep going dust
just go fast it talks about how i do
what you just said
you start with the show and then you go
into
go back dust one more
thank you see what happens you take the
show and then you look at all those
platforms
go to the next one dust forward slide 13
right and then you chop the little
pieces
and this is how you do it differently go
to next one so
incredibly interesting keep going i
think you'll find this
like this is something when this came
out everybody got mad at me
um or made jokes because they said all
the people trying to sell courses for
ten thousand dollars
all [ __ ] so this is super free uh it's
86 pages it's very detailed
and it will help you understand how i
think about it and i think it will help
you
train up or train your designers
i love it thank you so much yeah that
big piece of content
thank you all right amazing and i would
love to have you on the show
soon we'll do it i'm in dustin take care
of it for september
yay amazing thank you very much sorry
you got it take care bye-bye bye
[ __ ] give me value vinnie what's good
oh let's go
it's great to see you yeah how can i
help you talk to you
good to talk well i'm in an interesting
situation at the moment
i'll give a quick story so last year i
had the
very huge privilege to be part of team
garyvee brazil
and uh big shout out to the to the guys
and every one of these you guys
and that created that embedded such a
speed on content creation you're just
talking about the
the the content model with laura and
that just embedded in me so now i have a
huge
opportunity to be in a job that i love
doing it and
uh but i'm getting a bit of friction
where i think you want to go fast and
they want to go slow
exactly they too they too hang up on the
brakes get the lines and you gotta find
uh follow the fonts follow the callers
and i'm and i wanna be fast guys we need
to put out we need to put out
this is a good one we need to put out
and no no no no hold back delete delete
it so i i don't know how to find the
middle ground now the woman
98 of the world lives in the world that
you're living in right now
yeah listen i deal with it every day
with vaynermedia
all my clients are the same yeah so now
at the moment
i'm playing i'm playing the patience
game so
i'm quiet doing my work grinding every
day
but i'm waiting the opportunity of the
way they're coming they're coming to me
and say
oh why this is not happening well
because we're not being fast enough
i think what what i would do if i was
you was
is try to make a personal relationship
with the most senior boss
so they they like you so that they're at
some point
you could say to them hey let me tell
you what i learned on gary's team and
let me tell you what the problem is
that's the only way it gets fixed and
that happens
that already happens like we we do gym
together we
we're such a small crew but we do team
together we go we hang out together so
good i just i'm just what kind of
companies
well they are heavy tv advertising
backgrounds what kind of
what kind of what kind of brand is it oh
very like sleek minimalist like
what do you see what's the business
what's the business i forget about yeah
and media australia no i apologize
what's what
oh they're an agency yeah they are they
are an idiot you work at each other
yeah so they i work in an agency and
they
are are they the problem or is the
client the problem with subjectiveness
around creative
they they are a problem so so
that's going to be tough
you know why you have to change religion
oh [ __ ] it's religion
i know because i know i know one of the
one of the reasons and even my boss
mentioned many times to me that one of
the reasons they got me
in the team is because he wants to to go
only on social
but i'm finding that his insecurity and
a lot he's just
resisting to what i'm what i'm bringing
to
him and the reason the reason you got so
much enjoyment out of
team gary brazil is as you know
i mean this is me my purse me the human
and there's no friction because we trust
people
and we go that was so much fun
so much fun just go we got the video
let's put it out that's it guys you chop
it up that's it
trust most companies do a terrible job
trusting i trust my people 100
and then if they prove me wrong then you
know i talk or we fire or whatever it
may be but
um yeah well that's a tough one right
you gotta you gotta make them understand
that
a piece of social content is not like a
big television production it's there to
quickly get insights and awareness not
absolutely absolutely i even i
and if it doesn't work then you're going
to move on and you have to let them know
that
well that's what i'm prepared to do if
they if they're not willing to
and good news vaynermedia is coming to
australia in the next couple years so
we'll be ready for that
oh my man i'll be on it
i gotta run then i love you take care
yeah
vinnie with the vino i like that drop
the i add the o
let's go
what's up gary josh it's so good to see
you i'm glad they got you in
everybody watching josh it's an
incredible uh family member of the
vaynerx
universe and empathy and all that sent
me a really interesting email
and i said you know what this will help
so many people so instead of
me just replying to this i told the team
to reach out to him and get him on an
episode and i'm glad i didn't realize it
was gonna be today so i'm glad it's good
to see you
gary really appreciate that um i
actually
speaking about vaynerx i wanted to
congratulate you and the whole team for
the recent um
constellation brands um being acquired
by them thank you
proud and happy for you guys um yeah i
guess just to bring you back up to speed
here
um after my time working with you guys
at empathy um i was in the hiring
process
with uh this company called the chilezi
group they're uh the music management
company for like dj marshmallow
yeah so um i will you know super pumped
for that
and what ultimately ended up happening
was the position got dropped
due to covid uh like right right when
covet hit like uh the nba got shot down
like the following monday they were like
unfortunately like the positions like
can no longer be available due to the
pandemic
um so currently though um i am
good news i have i am a candidate for a
full-time role over at snapchat
and um so pumped about that however um
you know the timing of it currently um
it may not be working my best favor
um i'm glad you said that this this
question could help
some some people in these type
circumstances but uh
essentially um the day before my
interview my family and i came together
and um essentially said goodbye to my
aunt and
uncle who have been in critical
condition from covid
for like over a month and yeah thank you
appreciate it and
it's very hard and um i guess looking
back now if
i would have like known the amount of
stress it would have put me in
i would have opted into like possibly
rescheduling my interview with snapchat
but basically um i was wondering and i
want to keep things as professional as
possible with you know my interviewer
and everything
um but i haven't uh so basically that
night before
and it resulted in like zero sleep that
night and
um i feel like i um didn't
it affected my interview performance in
a negative way
um so my question to you is should i
let snapchat know my current situation
well in real life in real life before we
get into the answer that helps you and
everybody else but in real real life
our relationship send me an email with
who you interviewed and for what
position
and i will personally reach out to the
highest branch to see if i can help you
because that's what you earn when you
get to work with somebody who can help
so let me help you on that front
and see what i can do the actual answer
is depends
meaning you know there's a lot of
people that would interview you that
would look at that as an excuse even
they're not cold-hearted it's just
they're a cynical human
other people are bleeding hearts and
will say yes so i think you ask
regardless because there's no lose in
you reaching out and giving them that
you know that that answer it may
really fall short of like well crap you
know like
sorry this is the way life is and we
like somebody better anyway
even if you went from a 3 to a 10 of you
we like sally way better
i don't think there's any downside in
and asking
um my biggest concern for you josh is
that you dwell on it
okay i don't care if you reach out or
you don't reach out
i care about as you go on to your next
thing whether you interview for with
tick tock or instagram
or trailer or something tomorrow i
i you basically gotta understand that
that day is
over and nothing about it other than a
great learning experience for you
of like hey i think you should take huge
pride
in the fact that you're such a great kid
and a family man that
even your aunt and uncle is impacting
you that way
like that's nice i think that that's
great you know you were surprised by
your own reaction it probably means that
you have deeper emotional intelligence
and love
for your family and i think that's a
great accomplishment for you to learn
that at this young of an age
comma the game just moves forward
into only all the energy you're putting
towards should i reach out to snapchat
should i not
let me email gary all that energy should
be i'm going to triller
and tick tock and dubsmash and facebook
and instagram
if you want to go platform using their
comps and i'm going to apply for a job
there i'm going to [ __ ] annihilate it
offense instead of when i see so much
defense
100 and then for everybody's watching
when i talk about
hey work for people you admire work for
peter today
this is a great example you know uh he's
josh is going to email me now with
direct details and i'm going to go to
this hippie top i mean i'm not going to
undermine whoever he interviewed with so
i'm gonna reach out to that person first
and then go above that person if i have
to
that's the be that's the relationship
building you get when you work for
certain scenarios so those those are the
two insights
offense versus defense and be thoughtful
for where you pick
jobs because you want to build
relationships with good people who might
be able to help you long term
yeah 100 gary i generally really needed
to hear that
um thank you because honestly since that
day um i guess i haven't been looking
for other jobs because like
i feel like if i look for other jobs
it's like i don't have faith in like my
performance yeah judge i
i know you enough a little bit and you
know i'm very omnipresent with all my
employees
i want you to be more offense and like
look forward versus
i'm glad you picked up on that it's it
you dwelling or debating or rethinking
or should have like
none of there is no time machine right
and there's just perspective and
optimism and action
right right like to me like i get in i
want you to build
like the mindset of like yo [ __ ] you
snapchat watch what i'm about to go do a
tick tock you know what i mean like
that's
right you can't beat yourself up it was
a life event it happened boom let's move
i 100 agree with you gary that being
said you've got me so send me that info
and i'll see if i can help
okay thank you so much you take care of
the offense i'll take care of your
defense on this one
okay but uncle gary will be around all
the time so you need to you know what i
mean
when i'm not around or not available or
somebody out like you need to focus on
what you can do
100 yeah i really appreciate you guys
josh talk to you
you got it
this is good stuff let's keep going
chad hi how are you i'm well how are you
good very good um this is cool thank you
for having me
very very happy to do it happy to do it
um
all right so i'm a sports nutritionist
and i actually i laughed a couple i
forget with was on t with garyvee or
something else that i watched of you and
you said
you basically said you hate the question
uh what do you do
because i get that question i i do so
many different things it's hard to
answer that question
but uh i'm basically i'm a sports
nutritionist and what i do is i work
with athletes
i'm mostly kind of niche down to high
school and college athletes
i'm on the olympic registry so i work
with olympic athletes also
but uh but kind of lumped in with that i
also end up working with
adults because a lot of these athletes
parents are also
athletes in their own right and they end
up hiring me and i work with
so my niche is kind of expanded which is
part of my question to you but
basically i have two questions i'm going
to give you a little bit of background
before i get into that
but um i've always had an
entrepreneurial mind
in fact like even as a my mom just told
me she found a card in her
laundry room the other day i used to
make greeting cards and sell them to all
my neighbors and i would call them jenny
mark like instead of hallmark i would
say jenny
first of all that's amazing second of
all did your mom take a picture of that
she didn't no she didn't she threw it
out no
she has that it's still sitting in here
ask her to take a photo
send it to you i think that's an
incredible piece of content on your
instagram where you can talk about your
journey
that's cool that's cool thank you yeah
yeah
i'm not reading for nothing um obviously
kidding keep going but uh so i
i i'm almost 48 years old so i've had
quite a long journey in this sports
nutrition field
i um i was i was an okay high school
athlete
but i always knew in the back of my head
i was better i just didn't have it
together i didn't make the connection
between
food and performance i mean i was a kid
sitting on the side
eating cool ranch doritos of course like
every like everybody else our age group
oh yeah yeah for all the youngsters
watching us
you know 40 to 50 year old crew we
[ __ ]
you guys are doing it so much better we
ate straight trash
yeah we didn't know i mean i would go to
the hot dog truck before swim team
practice
you know of course
so long story short i ended up in
college and for some reason i just said
to myself you know i don't feel good
i don't look good i was about 19 years
old i'm going to buy a pair of running
shoes and i'm just
what happened the freshman 15 hit you a
little more
but it's so but it's so interesting
right it's so cliche right
keep going it is and and then i said i
like running i started to run
i don't know why i was the worst runner
ever in high school but i just started
it and then i started reading everything
about nutrition and i started cleaning
out my diet
and all of a sudden you know 40 pounds
later
and it wasn't so much about the pounds
as it was i started to
feel amazing and i've never felt that
way before
and i um then i went to this career talk
in college and they said to find a
career that you love
you just need to find something you love
to do and make a job out of it so i said
oh my god this is what i'm going to do
i'm going to be a sports nutritionist so
grad school and i did it the day i
graduated from grad school i started my
llc and i started a private practice
now at the same time i married someone
who is in medical school
so i kind of had to kind of get a real
job too but i always did both
so for years i did both and and we kind
of just did our thing
so in in our in my 20s i just i just ran
and i worked and i did marathon so i
didn't want to run
right i wanted to run marathons so i got
like zone
and then um just right towards the end
of my 20s
me and my husband started doing
triathlons together but we didn't just
want to do triathlons we wanted to do
iron man so we started training for iron
man right so crazy
yeah you go home then we wanted to have
kids so but we didn't want to just have
one we want to have four
so we have four pets so that takes me to
my 40s
where now it's all about the kids right
in there
and they're also athletes in their own
right which brings me back to me
and now i feel that it's time my kids
are between 11
and 16 now it's really time for me to
kind of up my my practice and real quick
a couple questions
couple questions did you ever call
yourself jenny miles
instead of giles like did that ever
happen no but that's really cute
thank you also big shout out to half mod
gang on twitch all right keep going
but my initials with my maiden name and
my married name is josh
so it's actually i've used that a couple
times but right now what i want to do is
i really want to serve i want to scale
my business a little bit reach more
people
it's all really been one-on-one i do
some public speaking i speak at prep
schools i speak to college teams high
school teams and that i'll still
love that in-person stuff but the rest
of it i really want to scale to more
you know maybe webinars which i've done
i've done small group webinars but i
really just kind of want to scale it
but my question to you is just from
watching you for the last year so you've
come up with some awesome ideas of just
creative out of the box ways of thinking
about how to reach
there's just so much misinformation
about sports nutrition and what should i
eat before a workout and after workout
and some of these products that kids are
using are dangerous and i wanted to be
kind of have did you go ham how long
have you been following me
about a year did you go ham on tick tock
i started um during covid this is the
thing and you'll love
me for this this is no different than
like you know why i'm excited
is you seem extremely goal-oriented and
execution-oriented
like you know jenny like it's super
simple
the answer to your question is tick tock
had you done four tick tocks a day with
and got good at it which i
really believe you would have just even
listening you would have made a single
like don't eat you know don't eat this
eat this right like like you would have
had one moment just like the gentleman i
don't know if you've been watching all
morning
you know like with the song you're you
literally know this because people you
know i'm sure moms through the years or
others are like hey i want to lose 15
and you're like do this and then they
don't do it right they
do candy instead of blueberries they
don't run
i've given you all the answers jenny you
just don't want to do it just like other
people don't want to run
yeah right right so just execute
execute you live this life in reverse
you're the one giving nutritional and
health advice to your inner circle your
cousins
your other mom's club kids and then they
don't execute and they're like eh
and you're like no no the like if you
put out
four tick tocks a day yeah
based on what you're doing that were
little tidbits of information
and you did it every day when you first
heard me say it which was not
during covet long before it right
i believe that you would have something
brewing i really believe that
okay okay i love that that's it
because that's doable that's it my
second question kind of related to that
is so because my niche is kind of
i mean it's not really that small it's
kind of bigger and i want it to be my
my niche is bigger too so you when you
put out four pieces of
or 15 pieces of content a day you can
get to all of them
when you only think of it as once every
three days you can't get this [ __ ]
jenny miles
[Laughter]
right right right your niche doesn't
scare me
what scares me is that you haven't made
the mental switch
just like the day before jenny freshman
40
didn't you know the day before when she
finally made the switch
everything changed i just need you to
get the switch on content creation
on 15 social networks the second i get
you there
it's game over right literally the day
before
you bought those running shoes and
started running you were at your lowest
point
yeah stuffing your face with [ __ ]
ding dongs and doritos
right and drinking beer and funneling
with those
frat boys right and then you said [ __ ]
that
and you you moved i am hoping this
moment right now
you know is that [ __ ] that moment and
you're like he's right and i'm going to
do
11 pieces of content tomorrow yeah yeah
running eating well in my world
is content for sure because it happens
so many times
a day right make yeah
okay i needed to hear that you could do
a whole pillar back on food
a whole pillar on like don't eat this
eat this
right yeah even though that's been done
before because i've seen that that's
done before it's just it's okay
everything on earth has been done before
that's true
i'm aware you know what else has been
doing you know what i've done before
eating well and working out which leads
to good results
right your success isn't at the expense
or be being taken away by somebody else
doing it
okay got it yeah cause it's just your
own twist on it right
that's right just you saying your mom
jenny mark
is unique me selling like every we've
got our own little
little things you are unique your advice
and what you and how you put it out and
execute that's important
because it's the truth all i'm do i'm
i'm talking [ __ ] that was talked about
in the 1200s
you know like my my advice is so [ __ ]
basic tried and true it's not even funny
i'm just unique in the way i communicate
it the delivery right
right and it's not the shtick it's just
me and you're going to be you and some
people
simon cynic is kind you know you know
like
you know holiday does it his way and
ferris does it his way and
oprah does it her way like you know just
be a human being
but put out good advice hey kids
you get tricked by those bars that look
healthy
let me flip the [ __ ] label for you
and look at this
horse [ __ ] eat [ __ ] blueberries
[ __ ]
blueberries are good got it i got it
see ya love you bye you're welcome so
much
does someone want to clip that and do
that as an igtv that whole thing i think
it's going to help people
roger clemens
you like that yeah
next one i'm going to do is rabbit by
the way plus is it weird that i thought
jessica rabbit which was a cartoon was
attractive in my early teenage years
like there was
i've always really questioned myself
about that i will admit
i have had the same thoughts i feel like
that one [ __ ] with us
like that wasn't nice to young boys like
i feel like they made us question like
a lot of things and she looked human
[Laughter]
she wasn't save you time let's keep it
moving
what's good my friend hi can you hear me
yes sir you
you can't hear me z
hello i could hear both of you so we can
hear you z
we can hear you okay you're back now
yeah got you on
apologies for that no worries how are
you and where are you from
i'm very well thank you um and i'm from
the uk
awesome what can i help you with okay so
just to give you some uh background
context so like
um i'm like the typical millennial that
wanted to change the world can't even
change the freaking light bulb
uh you know the bedroom bedroom
revolutionary full of
social anxiety self-esteem issues
and insecurities and all of that now
when i say this i'm not saying this is
because of anything that's happened in
my life like i've had a very blessed
life
and i'm aware that this is a direct
result of having a life of
comfort and ease uh and security but
um obviously i still have these issues
and i did well in the traditional rule
in
in terms of you know i was the teacher's
pet kind of guy followed rules
did as i was told uh did well at school
got good grades
qualified as a lawyer um even opened up
my law firm but i absolutely hated every
single
freaking minute of it um and you know so
over the last few years i've tried to
move into the entrepreneurial uh
arena um which has been difficult and
this is where you've come in because
i mean your entire your entire youth
structure
makes it very very difficult because you
were very smart and good and capable
in working within a system
entrepreneurship is outside of the
system
yes makes sense exactly that so
the biggest struggle for me has
obviously because i've always relied on
um asking for permission and and getting
you know validation from other people
and obviously when you in the
entrepreneurship group there's no one
there to get it from
um except except you so you know i got a
lot of my permission
thank you or the market the market
the market the market is my
affirmation you know the people getting
value out of what i'm trying to put out
whether that was
a good price on a bottle of wine whether
that was
a cool sneaker at a good price whether
that is free content
uh but keep going yeah so so this
the first thing was obviously the second
thing that i got from you was if you
don't know what you want to do if you
don't know what your passion is
just try stuff so i'll be trying so many
things you know i i did
facebook advertising copyrighted uh
dropshipping white labeling the whole
shipment i literally went from being a
hotshot lawyer
to slinging pregnancy pillows on on
instagram
you know um so i'm still trying to find
my way
um
do you have um do you have actually go
ahead you were about to ask a question
i'll ask mine after go ahead
so so yes i'm still trying to find my
way um and
and because i'm still kind of trapped
between the corporate world and the
entrepreneurial world because it hasn't
quite worked for me yet um and you know
i've been obviously watching a lot of
your videos and you know i think a few
weeks ago you had a guy called
uh alexis one and he was talking about
how he's cynical and negative all the
time
and uh he's got all of these issues et
cetera you know it was like listening to
myself a few years ago and you know i've
always been
scared and fearful and i still am but
the difference is now
before when i was scared i didn't do
anything now i'm still scared and i'm
trying to do things good news i'm so
[ __ ] proud of you
thank you and this will make sense to
you scared of not doing anything which
is the majority of people who are
watching right now
scared but starting to do something
you're now at half time
soon we're going to be and how old are
you
i'm 54. perfect young and at 38
you'll be not scared of doing something
and at 42
you'll maybe get to a place where you're
really executing
in a great place if you're not scared of
putting in the work for the next eight
years you'll have 50 years of happiness
in front of you post 42.
yeah it's exactly that because like you
know looking back one of the
biggest issues was as you say impatience
um because in school
you were getting affirmation weekly by
the test
yes you know monthly by the progress
report
quarterly by the report card
exactly exactly that yeah yeah so i'm
basically i've been reconditioning
myself and rewiring myself and building
the self-esteem and
you know getting over the insecurity
issues a lot of that has come down to
the conversation i've been having with
myself
but the voice in my head has been you
watching you know obviously your
your programs and stuff um so
my question it's a double dollar
question which i'm pretty getting a lot
of anxiety trying to ask it because
real quick where do you live in uk i
have a big idea right now where do you
live in the uk
i live in a small town called buttley
seen between leeds and bradford
beautiful butley batley b-a-t-l-y
batley sadly anybody who's watching
right now
if you're part of our community because
i think the other thing you need z and a
lot of people need is a couple of
friends of optimism and positivity yeah
you know
you know um so if anybody
watching right now is in that general
area please dm
our friend here and i think you two post
covet i don't know
the state of the union right now in the
uk but
you should get together for for a pint
or a coffee or a tea
um because you if you know i believe
this
can i believe in this community the most
and if i'm the one
positive voice for many what i've been
thinking a lot about is
if i can add all of you meeting each
other
and now you have two or three friends of
positivity
now becomes sustainable and then it
becomes your culture and then it becomes
your religion
yeah absolutely as a matter of fact
everybody in the comments section right
now
please leave your city uh and state
and country in your comments linkedin
youtube facebook everybody
and then everybody go back and re-watch
us and see all the answers and start
messaging each other if you live
near each other yeah so quickly what i
want to ask you is basically i've done a
lot of work now
i followed your advice put up content um
about my issues let me start putting out
videos which was the real big big
breakthrough
in helping with the self-esteem issues
and stuff but what i want to do now
thinking is i want to help other people
that have got self-esteem issues and
not yet okay i'll tell you why
right i think you're smart enough to
realize that there's opportunities
financially there
but i think you're at half time i don't
this is the question i don't want to
monetize it because the people that i
want to help i don't want to find
respect i just don't know if you're at
the place yet
where you're on i feel like you're on
one foot and i'd rather you be on two
feet before you start helping
because you're still in your own journey
it might just be a little bit early i'd
rather you execute
on a tangible business and then
that'd be my preference because i see
people jump into it a hair early
yeah okay okay remember if you're gonna
help somebody you need to be able to
really help them
yeah and and sometimes people jump into
helping people when they're not ready to
help them which hurts those people
yeah and look i used to do it a lot
before but then the
root took over and uh basically i
stopped helping people because
i was gonna you know been being a yes
man um
everybody else came no i don't want i
don't want to be a no man you can do
whatever you want
just keep in mind if you're actually
prepared for it
and number two and you know that see
it's all just about putting out the
content and creating a community
like you can post on your linkedin and
instagram right now and say
hey join me on live tonight from 7 to
eight pm and if four people show up
you've started the process
yeah brilliant okay so the the the thing
that was causing me anxiety was
i want to start like a podcast about
self-esteem issues so
the request was would you be one of my
guests honey i will be your 55th guest
if you show me that you can do 54
episodes i will 100
be your 55th guest brilliant don't
thank you see i'll see you soon i got
one minute i got to go into a client
thing
thank you everybody in the vaynernation
hope you enjoyed today's show i thought
it was
fantastic dustin your thoughts oh dustin
do you have the hot ones episode
i do i do i do the best um
everybody if you haven't seen this we're
about to put it on you're going to be
blown away
um and i hope you're uh
super well and i hope that uh
everything is great and you have a
wonderful weekend
and you deploy kindness and
self-awareness and
execution and patience and all the
things that ultimately get
to the places we need to and uh i hope
uh hope everyone's super good
simple as that and just give me some
shout outs natasha thank you for
watching ross greenberg
always good to see you melvin lee thank
you daisy nicole thank you
tommy tom thank you i'm a mma guy
appreciate it jennifer dalton thank you
so much
deez nicole thank you louis pro
lewis if you're talking about me i
apologize you feel that way and i hope
we get to meet one day
get to know each other better um hope
everybody's super good
and um have a great great weekend we'll
talk soon see ya